c'est pas vrai comment vas tu tu vas
bien aux longs mois sera pas du tout ça
va pas c'est pas vrai mais tais toi
qu'est-ce qui se passe bon les tas de
trucs ça va pas je te lis c'est pas vrai
mais tais toi raconte qu est-ce qu il ya
un jeu pas grave tu regardes autour de
toi ça peut pas aller c'est tout c'est
pas vrai et tétouan mais qu'est-ce qu'il
ya ragoût de pois se penche déjà regarde
le vietnam pour le moyen-orient c'est
pas vrai et tais toi mais raconte qu'est
ce qu'il y a papy c'est pas tout en plus
ma femme c'est pas vrai tétouan et bien
pourtant qu'est-ce qu'il ya non écoute
alors si tu dis c'est pas vrai et
tétouan à tout ce que je te dis hein moi
je te fous mon poing dans la gueule
c'est pas vrai enfin j'ai quand même un
petit espoir quoi c'est vrai je me dis
que si ça s'arrange avec ma femme en
principe le vietnam et le moyen-orient
ça doit suivre